>> Tucker: BIG TECH FIRMS HAVE
SWEEPING THE POWER THAT
AUTHORITARIAN DICTATORS ONCE
DREAMED OF.
SOMEWHERE IN A VERY HOT PLACE,
NIKOLAI CHA-CHA SCHEDULES AND
ENVY.
THEY CAN IN JUST SECONDS,
ARTICLES AND GOVERNMENT HAS
PLACED NO LIMITS ON THESE POWERS
SO INCREASINGLY THE CENSORSHIP
IS TOTALLY BRAZEN.
IT’S OUT IN THE OPEN AND THEY
DON’T CARE.
WHEN DONALD TRUMP JR. POSTED THE
PHOTO OF DOCTORS CHALLENGING THE
CORONAVIRUS STORY LINE AND
ADDING THEIR OWN VIEWS ON IT AS
ENTITLED, TWITTER SUSPENDED HIS
ACCOUNT AND DELETED THE TWEET.
EVEN THAT WASN’T ENOUGH FOR THE
GHOULS AT CNN.
THEY COMPLAINED THAT TRUMP’S
ACCOUNT WASN’T SENSITIVE ENOUGH.
>> FROM MY UNDERSTANDING IN
TERMS OF THIS TWITTER
RESTRICTION FOR TWEETING FOR
DON JR. IS 12 HOURS.
SO MY QUESTION IS HOW MANY
PEOPLE SAW THIS AND BELIEVED
THIS BEFORE ACTION WAS TAKEN.
TALK ABOUT IF YOU UNDERSTAND THE
POLITICS BEHIND OF THE
PRESIDENTS ON TWEETING FALSEHOOD
DESPITE TWITTER SUSPENDING HIS
ACCOUNT AND RESTRICTING HIS
ACCOUNT.
THE CAT IS OUT OF THE BAG, YOU
CAN’T CHANGE IT.
>> IT’S DISTURBING.
IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE AND IT
COST LIVES.
>> WE NEVER DREAMED WE’D LIVE TO
SEE JOURNALISTS CALLING FOR MORE
CENSORSHIP BUT THAT’S WHERE WE
ARE.
DONALD TRUMP JR. IS THE AUTHOR
OF THE NEW BOOK LIBERAL
PRIVILEGE.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO I JUST HAVE TO ASK YOU THE
BLOOD TEST POSSIBLE QUESTION
WITH RESPECT.
GIVEN THE LEVEL OF CENSORSHIP
IMPOSED ON YOU AND ANYONE WHO
SUPPORTS THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT, DOES THE INCUMBENT
HAVE A CHANCE OF GETTING
REELECTED?
>> LISTEN.
I’VE BEEN SAYING THIS FOR A LONG
TIME, I WROTE MY FIRST BOOK
ABOUT JUSTICE, CENSORSHIP COMING
FROM THE BIG TECH GIANTS AT AND
AS HOMOGENOUS GROUP AS YOU COULD
POSSIBLY IMAGINE.
IF THEY ARE CENSORING MY
ACCOUNT, THEY ARE CENSORING
OTHERS AND THEY’VE BEEN TRYING
TO DO THIS FOR A WHILE.
I’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE D
PLATFORMING, THAT THE
MONETIZATION OF PEOPLE BECAUSE
TUCKER, YOU HAVE TO NOTE, THIS
NEVER HAPPENS TO SOMEONE SAYING
SOMETHING THAT BENEFITS THE
LEFT.
IT ONLY HURTS CONSERVATIVES.
WHEN I POSTED THAT VIDEO I
DIDN’T SAY THIS GOSPEL, I SAID
THIS IS A MUST WATCH BECAUSE IT
SEEMS VERY CONTRARY TO THE
NARRATIVE THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
FORCE-FEEDING US FOR A LITTLE
WHILE.
NOW TWITTER TAKES ME DOWN FOR
THAT BUT TWITTER HAS NO PROBLEM
SAYING THAT CORONAVIRUS --
DISINFORMATION SPREAD BY THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT DOES NOT
VIOLATE THE RULES, AND THAT’S
INTERESTING.
IT HAPPENS ALL ONE-WAY.
IT WAS VERY NICE WATCHING THE
PEOPLE FROM CNN AND MSNBC
BECAUSE JAMES TAPPER HIMSELF
POSTED, A STUDY FINDS
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE AND HELPED
PATIENTS SURVIVE BETTER.
WHY IS NOT JAKE TAPPER SPREADING
THIS INFORMATION?
I’M NOT A DOCTOR AND I DON’T
CLAIM TO BE BUT I PUT SOMETHING
OUT THERE THAT CHALLENGES THE
NARRATIVE.
BECAUSE I HAVE A LARGE PLATFORM,
I’M CANCELED.
YOU KNOW WHO ELSE GOT THROWN OUT
OF TWITTER FOR THE SAME OFFENSE?
SIDNEY POWELL WHO HAPPENS TO BE
MICHAEL FLYNN’S ATTORNEY AND
SOMEONE WHO HAS BEEN STICKING IT
TO THE LEFT.
SO IF FAKE JAKE AT CNN NO ONE IS
GOING TO CONFUSE AS A
CONSERVATIVE CAN PUT IT BUT NOT
BE CENSORED, NOT BE QUESTIONED
AND CERTAINLY NOT BE GRILLED BY
A PANEL OF HIS PEERS ON CNN, WHY
IS IT THAT IT’S HAPPENING TO ME
AND OTHER TRUMP CONSERVATIVES
AND OTHER CONSERVATIVES IN
GENERAL?
>> Tucker: IF I SEE ANOTHER
REPUBLICAN OFFICEHOLDER BACKED
BY GOOGLE AND THE CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE LECTURE ME THAT IT’S
NOT REALLY CENSORSHIP BECAUSE
THE GOVERNMENT ISN’T DOING, I’M
GOING TO GO BANANAS.
I MEAN IT, IS THERE ANYBODY IN
POWER WHO CAN STEP IN TO DEFEND
THE MOST BASIC RIGHT OF ALL OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WHICH IS TO
SAY WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE?
>> I THINK JOSH HAWLEY IN THE
SENATE HAS DONE VERY GOOD
CHALLENGING THIS.
KEVIN McCARTHY IN THE HOUSE
HAS DONE THE SAME THING.
AND THAT’S A PROBLEM.
I’VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS FOR
THREE YEARS AND THEY SEE WHAT
HAPPENS TO MY TWITTER FITA, I
KNOW WHAT I’M GOING TO GET
BEFORE I HIT SEND.
THEY ARE DOING WHAT THEY CAN.
I DID A PANEL WITH JOSH AND
KEVIN McCARTHY AND THEY ARE
AWARE.
THE REAL PROBLEM IS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CONSERVATIVE
LEGISLATORS AND REPUBLICANS HAVE
NO IDEA THAT THIS ISSUE IS EVEN
GOING ON.
MORE IMPORTANTLY THEY DON’T EVEN
REALIZE THAT IT’S PROBABLY A TOP
TWO OR THREE ISSUE WITH AIR
BASE.
IF YOU ARE RELIGIOUS, IF YOU ARE
PRO-LIFE, IF YOU ARE
PRO-SECOND AMENDMENT, LOOK AT
YOUR ANALYTICS.
THE GONE THROUGH THE FLOOR.
IT’S BEEN A DISASTER AND IT
HAPPENS SYSTEMATICALLY ON
PURPOSE AND IT’S GONE NOW FOR
YEARS.
THEY HAVE TO WAKE UP.
>> Tucker: BEFORE YOU GO, I
CAN’T RESIST GETTING A REVIEW
OF.
HERE’S CONGRESSMAN JERRY NADLER
OF MANHATTAN RESPONDING TO A
QUESTION ABOUT THE VIOLENCE.
WATCH THIS.
>> I WOULD REMIND MR. JORDAN,
MR. BAIG AND MR. JOHNSON TO STOP
VIOLATING THE RULES OF THE
COMMITTEE, STOP VIOLATING THE
SAFETY OF THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND TO STOP HOLDING
EACH OTHER OUT AS NOT CARING BY
REFUSING TO WEAR THEIR MASKS.
>> Tucker: DIFFERENT CLIP BUT
EQUALLY NUTS, WHAT DO YOU THINK
OF THAT?
>> THIS IS TYPICAL DEMOCRAT, DO
AS I SAY AND NOT AS I DO."
HE WAS DENYING THAT ANYTHING WAS
EVEN GOING ON IN PORTLAND AS I
RELATE TO THE VIOLENCE THAT WAS
DECIMATING DEMOCRAT-CONTROLLED
CITIES.
AGAIN, 19 OF THE TOP 20 CITIES
IN THE COUNTRY ARE DEMOCRAT RUN
AND DEMOCRAT MAYORS WHO APPOINT
DEMOCRATS ACROSS THE BOARD.
IN MANY CASES THESE CITIES HAVE
BEEN RUN BY DEMOCRATS FOR OVER
100 YEARS BUT MAGICALLY, IT’S
DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
IT WAS DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT WHEN
HE SENT FEDERAL OFFICERS TO HELP
AND ASSIST THE PORTLAND PD WHICH
BY THE WAY WERE UNDER ATTACK
EVERY NIGHT FOR FIVE WEEKS PRIOR
TO THE THOSE OFFICERS BEING
THERE.
BUT AGAIN IT’S MAGICALLY
DONALD TRUMP’S FAULT.
BUT THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
THE NEWS THAT IS GETTING
DISSEMINATED TO THE AVERAGE GUY,
YOU AND ME, WE PERHAPS DO THIS
STUFF ALL WEEK LONG BUT IF YOU
ARE A HARDWORKING MAN OR WOMAN
AND PUTTING FOOD ON THE TABLE
AND CONSUMING FIVE OR 10 MINUTES
OF NEWS, AND IT’S THAT FILTERED
AND THAT BIASED, THAT IS THE
LENS BY WHICH YOU ARE GETTING
YOUR NEWS, AND IT’S HARD TO MAKE
AN ACCURATE OPINION BECAUSE YOU
ARE BEING SPOON-FED ALL THESE
THINGS AND THAT IS THEIR
INTENTION.
>> Tucker: AND THEN YOU WIND
UP GETTING A HEALTH LECTURE FROM
JERRY NADLER AND NOBODY LAUGHS.
>> THAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE
GREAT IRONIES OF ALL TIME.
>> Tucker: IT’S REALLY